اخا ونصيرا للامه العربيه
وتضامنا معها في الظروف الدقيقه التي تمر
بها
يسعدني كذلك
ان اعرب عن جزيل الشكر لخادم الحرمين
الشريفين
واليوليه لاحدى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وكذا الاستراحه
في هذا الدول العظات في الجامع العربي
هذه في ظرف بالق الدقه
اقليميا معالم عالميا السيده الامينه
العام للانسان
[موسيقى]
في مناطق شاسعه امامكم اليوم من العالم
ممثلا للاتحاد
التي تمر بها اما في ساحه العربيه
ويتواصل
الاسرائيلي على الشعب الفلسطيني الحرمين
الشريفين وتتضعف
لدعوه الاخويه احتلال
المستوطنين قصرا وكذا واستقبال الحار
والضياف الكريمه التي حظين بها في هذا
البلد العزيز وارضه المقدسه
تنعقدهمتكم هذه في ظرف بالق الدقه
اقليميا وعالميا
على صعيد الدولي
تستمر الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
المدمره للانسان والاقتصاديات العديد من
الدول ليس فقط في اوروبا بل في مناطق
شاسعه
من العالم
انها تهدد العالم
بشحه شديده في مصادر الطاقه
والقزاع والامن والاستقرار
اما في ساحه العربيه
فيتواصل العدوان الاسرائيلي على الشعب
الفلسطيني
وتتضاعف الاهانات ضده
وتتسع رقعه السلبه من اراضيه
واحتلال افواج المستوطنين قصرا وظلما
وعدوانا لمساحات حساسه منها كما يطول صمت
العالم المريب على هذه التراجديه المستمره
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني المحروم من حقه في
الحريه
وتاسيس دولته المستقله ذات السياده التامه
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
وبمناسبه الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين لنكبه
المجتمه القوي فاننا الامراض بشده ذلك
العدوان المستمر ونطالب لجهود الدوليه
وربما اخير
خاصه
والمحافظه في هذه الاسماء لقد استمروا
الافريقي
السودانيين في هذه المرحله انتقاليه
ما ادى وتوحيد
في السلطه واللجوء الى العنف لحل الخلافات
بين الشركاء السي والعسكريين ان الاتحاد
الافريقي الذي كان اول من دعا للثلاثيه
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد
ورتبها قد بادر منذ شراره الاولى للاقتتال
الراهن بالدعوه الى توحيد جهود المنظومه
الدوليه
اننا في الاتحاد الافريقي نرى ان بعثرت
جهود المنظومه الدوليه قد تكون من مسببات
اطاله الصراع كما علمتنا التجربه في عديد
من البلدان وفي هذا السياق رحبنا بجهود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لحمل الطرفين
على وقف اطلاق النار وفتح الطريق امام
المساعدات الانسانيه لشعب السوداني
المنكوب اصحاب الجلال والصهي والمعالي
ايها الساده والسيدات اننا نؤمن بان
الصراع في السودان لن يكون له حل عسكري
نهائي وليس من مصلحه الشعب السوداني ولا
المنطقه ان يكون له حل عسكري ان الذين
تسولوا لهم انفسهم بذلك انما يعيشون على
الاوهام وهم مهما كانوا غير مبالين بما
يلحقه في العنف من دمار الدوله ومؤسسات
البلاد وبنيتها التحيه التحتيه وزحر وزحق
ارواح ابنائها
ان مغامره العنف تهدد تهديدا جديا المنطقه
كلها بالفوضى والحرب الاهليه والماسي بلا
نهايه اننا اننا ندعو الى تشكيل كتله
دوليه
تتبوا فيها الاتحاد الافريقي والجامعه
العربيه والامم المتحده والايجاد وغيرهم
من القوه الفاعله في الساحه السودانيه
كالرباعيه دورا رياضيا مركزيا وذلك من اجل
تعزيز الجهود الراميه الى السلام
واستئناف المسلسل السياسي لقيام حكومه
مدنيه تواجه التحديات العاجله وتعيد
المسار الانتقالي الى سكته تحضيرا
لانتخابات عامه حره ونزيهه اننا نهيب بهذه
القمه ان تتخذ في هذا التوجه قرارات حاسمه
قويه ونافسه لا شك ان قراراتكم في هذا
الشان وغيره من القضايا ذات الصله سيكون
له الايجابي على ما ستدرسه وتغرر فيه
القمه العربيه الافريقيه التي ستنعقد هنا
في هذا البلد في هذه البلاد الطيبه بحر
السنه الجاريه اتمنى لقوتكم نجاحا باهرا
سدد الله
عليكم و رحمه الله و بركاته لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات